AND WHYS OF THE SEX TAPE,
I ASKED MY INTERN TO COMPILE
THE ESSENTIALS OF THE GENRE.
- SO, UH, 1 NIGHT IN PARIS.
THIS IS KIND OF LIKE
THE APOCALYPSE NOW
OF CELEBRITY SEX TAPES.
THEN YOU'VE GOT PAMELA ANDERSON
AND TOMMY LEE,
WHICH IS KIND OF LIKE
THE CITIZEN KANE, I GUESS?
- WAIT, WAIT.
TURN ON YOUR FILTER LIGHT.
- IN SHORT ORDER,
THE HOW WAS CLEAR ENOUGH--
DIRTY TALK
AND CONFUSING SEXUAL POSITIONS--
BUT THE WHY REMAINED ELUSIVE.
THAT IS DISGUSTING.
THERE'S A VERY GOOD REASON
THAT MOST PEOPLE HAVE SEX
IN THE DARK.
IT FEELS BETTER THAN IT LOOKS.
THANK YOU, LUCILLE.
- OH.
TAKE IT!
- ROB LOWE, HUH?
[indistinct chatter
on computer]
- IT SIMPLY DIDN'T MAKE SENSE
TO ME.
JUST BREAKS MY HEART HOW--
- CAN WE NOT TALK?
I REALLY JUST WANT TO FOCUS
ON THIS.
- OH, YEAH
- OKAY.
IN ORDER TO UNDERSTAND
THE APPEAL OF MAKING A SEX TAPE,
I WAS GOING TO NEED THE
ASSISTANCE OF A WILLING PARTNER.
- HAVE YOU OUTDONE YOURSELF?
- I THINK I HAVE OUTDONE MYSELF.
ASK ME WHY I MADE
MY SPECIALTY TONIGHT.
- WHY DID YOU MAKE
YOUR SPECIALTY TONIGHT, HONEY?
- WELL, JUST FOR THE HALIBUT.
[both laughing]
THAT'S A LOT OF FUN.
- THAT IS A LOT OF FUN.
- TO US.
- TO US. MM.
both: MMM.
- HEY, LISTEN, I TOLD ERIC
THAT HE SHOULD STAY OVER
AT CLAYTON'S HOUSE TONIGHT.
- OH, OKAY.
I HAVE A SHOPPING LIST FOR YOU,
IF YOU DON'T MIND.
- SHOPPING LIST?
NO, NO, NO.
NO, I THOUGHT
WE MIGHT DO SOMETHING
A LITTLE MORE INTERESTING
WITH OUR ALONE TIME.
- OH, OKAY, I GET IT, YEAH.
- UH-HUH, YEAH.
IN FACT, I THOUGHT WE MIGHT...
- OH, ALL RIGHT.
- MIX IT UP
A LITTLE BIT TONIGHT.
- WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?
- I WAS THINKING WE MIGHT
DOCUMENT THE PROCEEDINGS
CE SOIR--
TONIGHT.
- WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
- HMM?
- HOW--HOW WOULD WE--
- I BOUGHT A VIDEO CAMERA,
AND I THOUGHT WE COULD--
- UGH!
YOU WANT TO MAKE A SEX TAPE?
- YEAH!
- NO, GROSS!
- WHY?
- WHAT ARE YOU,
A FRESHMAN IN COLLEGE?
NO, NO, NO.
WHAT IF PEOPLE SAW IT?
WHAT IF ERIC FOUND IT?
- NO, DON'T--
SWEETHEART, WE'LL MAKE SURE ERIC
DOESN'T SEE IT
UNTIL LONG AFTER WE'RE DEAD.
- NO, THAT IS NOT--
I CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE
YOU WOULD WANT TO DO--
THAT'S NOT LIKE YOU.
IT'S CREEPY.
- I'M VERY SURPRISED
BY THIS REACTION OF YOURS.
- [sighs]
- I THOUGHT YOU MIGHT THINK
IT WOULD BE KIND OF FUN.
- MAN, FORREST.
- I THINK IT WOULD BE FUN.
- YOU WERE SO CLOSE, YOU KNOW?
YOU WERE ON THE GREEN!
ALL YOU HAD TO DO WAS
JUST PUTT IT.
- THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
I WAS DOING.
- NO, YOU SHANKED IT RIGHT
INTO THE WOODS!
THANKS FOR NOTHING, ALL RIGHT?
- WELL, THINK ABOUT IT.
- I THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
NO.
[light switch clicks]